en 2010 avait lieu la catastrophe de la
plateforme deepwater horizon dans le
golfe du mexique
dix ans plus tard les conséquences
environnementales demeure inquiétante
le 20 avril 2010 à une soixantaine de km
des côtes de louisiane
l'horreur se produit à 21h56 la plate
forme de forage deepwater rising explose
la cause une remontée soudaine d'une
bulle de méthane 11ème périssent c'est
le début d'un des pires désastres
environnementaux de l'histoire
[Musique]
l'amérique entière retient son souffle
les marées noires se répandent sur la
côte du texas à la floride
les images d'animaux englués dans le
pétrole font le tour du monde
dix ans après la catastrophe
les scientifiques réalise la véritable
ampleur des dégâts et le désastre
s'étend bien au delà du vice et samantha
joy est océanographe
elle étudie alors le golfe du mexique
quand la plateforme s'est effondré j'ai
eu ce noeud dans l'estomac qui est
restée pendant des mois et des mois avec
ses équipes elles restent les mois
suivants sur l'eau elle recueille les
données les plus complètes sur la
catastrophe à 1500 mètres sous la
surface
la tête du puits crash un flot continu
de pétrole et gaz des centaines de
barrages flottants tente de retenir le
pétrole jour et nuit des bateaux mènent
des opérations de brûlage contrôler mais
ça ne suffit pas
bp entreprend alors une expérience sans
précédent
l'épandage massif de corexit un
dispersants chimiques aux effets méconnu
deux millions de litres ont été répandus
c'est la plus grande utilisation de
dispersant dans l'histoire des
catastrophes pétrolières l'espoir de bp
c'est que le seulement facilite
l'absorption des hydrocarbures dans la
chaîne alimentaire sous marine
d'abord le dispersant fractionne le
pétrole en micro gouttelettes une
émulsion que les micro organismes
présents dans l'eau pourront ensuite
ingérée mais est ce vraiment ce qui se
passe ce n'est pas bio dégradé le
pétrole c'est juste déplacer on ne peux
plus le voir par satellite
donc on ne peut plus le suivre ça le
rend invisible loin des yeux loin de
l'esprit aussi aujourd'hui que dans ces
conditions les dispersants inhibe
l'activité microbienne pire et décompose
le pétrole en sous-produits plus
toxiques que le pétrole lui même
alors que bp s'affairent à disperser le
pétrole à la surface
samantha joy et son équipe mettent à
jour un autre problème invisible un
panache de pétrole et de gaz sous marin
flottant entre deux eaux de 35 km de
long bp en y d'abord l'existence
personne n'a admis l'existence de ce
panache sous marins jusqu'au matin où je
devais témoigner devant le congrès ne
pas tenir compte de ce panache et pour
samantha joy une erreur grave qui a
contribué à l'échec des tentatives pour
colmater le puits ne pas déterminer avec
précision le débit quotidien de la fuite
était une énorme erreur de calcul
non seulement parce que ça a été
impossible de restreindre sa propagation
mais aussi parce que c'est un hymne et
tous les efforts pour boucher le puits
c'était impossible de le faire 87 jours
c'est le temps qu'il a fallu à bp pour
colmater la fuite
l'équivalent de 26 mille camions
citernes se sont répandus dans le golfe
du mexique
un désastre écologique inimaginable
cela ressemblait à l'enfer
en 2010 il n'y avait plus rien de vivant
dans le fond c'était horrible on évalue
à présent qu entre 3 à 20 % du pétrole
s'est déposée dans les fonds marins
cette couche épaisse est encore là
aujourd'hui presque intacte
dauphins tortues cachalot les poissons
toute la chaîne alimentaire s'est
effondré après la catastrophe
dans combien de temps elle se rétablira
personne n'a la moindre idée
le puits de deepwater horizon
il y a dix ans se situer à 1500 mètres
sous la surface
aujourd'hui 54 % des forages golfe du
mexique sont plus profond encore
il a fallu 90 jours pour colmater un
puits à 1500 mètres sous l'eau imaginez
la même situation à 3000 mètres de
profondeur dans des puits super gazeux
c'est insensé d'y penser
dix ans plus tard
samantha joy n'est pas au bout de ses
surprises ces données ont servi à
élaborer un modèle informatique de la
catastrophe ici on voit l'estimé de la
superficie contaminé le modèle révèle en
fait qu'elle était 30% plus large
qu'estimé ou pire de la crise
l'essentiel c'est que ce n'est pas une
industrie durable
les réservoirs de pétrole et de gaz se
remplissent sur une période de dix
millions d'années
il n'y a absolument aucun moyen de
rendre sa durable pour ces experts si on
persiste à forer tôt ou tard surviendra
un autre accident mais cette fois alors
à la lumière des nouvelles connaissances
il ne sera plus possible de nier les
ravages du pétrole invisible